so changing your mind when there are  reasons to change your mind is  absolutely a sign of rationality and  conversely uh the personality trait of  steadfastness stubbornness pride uh is a  very good way of being irrational  there's a quote attributed to john  maynard keynes falsely as it turns out  when the when he changes his mind on  something  so the story goes and he said when the  facts change i changed my mind what do  you do sir now it turns out he didn't  say it exactly uh probably paul  samuelson did but it is a  a wise criterion for rationality and  indeed um  there's a a kind of a trait almost more  of a personality trait than an  intellectual trait of sometimes called  openness to evidence  namely when the facts change do you  change your mind uh people vary because  there are some people who  think that it's a sign of character  weakness to change your mind and it is  rational obviously to change your mind  you